57 prozent der deutschen sagen sie
vertrauen diesen zahlen vom robert koch
institut nicht das ist eine alarmmeldung
auch für die aktuelle bundesregierung
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit dem
künftigen fdp generalsekretär mit design
djir sarai der bei uns ist heute früh
schönen guten tag guten tag grüße sie
die mehrheit der deutschen vertraut
diesen zahlen nicht vertrauen sie ja
oder nein
ich vertraue allerdings sage ich ganz
offen dass ich mich weniger mit den
zahlen beschäftigen das sollten unsere
experten tun darf wir haben wir auch
gremien was für mich interessant ist
oder was für mich relevant sind sind die
politischen schlussfolgerungen daraus
wie wir insgesamt mit der situation
umgehen und vor allem endlich aus dieser
situation herauskommen
diese schlussfolgerungen gleich mal
reden aber sie sagten ja auch ganz
richtig die orientieren sich ja an den
zahlen also man orientiert sich ganz
klar daran dass das robert koch institut
liefert jetzt hakt aber da natürlich
auch über die feiertage man testet sich
weniger es wird weniger gemeldet
letztendlich sind wir in einer art
grauzone und wissen und können ja somit
überhaupt gar keine politischen
maßnahmen besprechen es wird sich alles
jetzt heute an diesem stichtag
entscheiden die schulen die testen jetzt
und da sehen wir dann die wahren zahlen
können sie die verunsicherung verstehen
brauchen wir vielleicht ja irgendwelche
neuen werte oder anders gemessene werte
damit sich die politischen maßnahmen der
zielgerichteter orientieren kommen also
noch mal entscheidend sind die
politischen schlussfolgerungen werte
haben wir aus meiner sicht genug
statistik aber genug zahlen haben wir
genug betrachtet aber dass
beispielsweise über das wochenende oder
über feiertage dass wir da gewisse
schwankungen bei den zahlen haben
unsicherheiten haben das liegt aus
meiner sicht in der natur der sache dass
ist auch ein phänomen das wir schon seit
längerem kennen ich persönlich komme
selbst beruflich aus seiner verwaltung
ich weiß wie verwaltungen arbeiten
ich weiß wie gesundheitsämter arbeiten
ich weiß wie schwierig dort die
kapazitäten sind und natürlich auch das
thema digitalisierung das heißt es
fehlen nach wie vor instrumente um sehr
zeitnah auch realitätsnahe daten ist es
geht dass sie so hin da sagen sie das
ist so in der verwaltung das müssen wir
halt so akzeptieren nein das dürfen wir
auf keinen fall akzeptieren denn die
digitalisierung in den öffentlichen
ämtern vor allem bei gesundheitsämtern
das ist eine große herausforderung aber
dieses immer hätte eigentlich schon
vorgestern erledigt sein müssen wir
brauchen die die digitalisierung in der
öffentlichen verwaltung denn sonst und
das ist glaube ich auch in dieser
pandemische situation ganz klar gezeigt
worden digitalisierung kann leben retten
immer wieder ist ja auch die rede davon
dass man auch eine art register schaffen
muss diese zahlen besser zusammen zu
fassen dass man das eigentlich auch
nicht nur dem rk ii überlassen kann sind
sie dafür dass andere behörden des
ministerien dass man eher eine neue form
der zahlen erschaffung schafft ich bin
kein freund dieser diskussion wissen sie
letztendlich reden wir hier nur um
basisdaten wir befassen uns eigentlich
wir reden auch jetzt gerade nur über die
frage wie man welche zahlen
zusammenträgt wichtig ist letztendlich
die schlussfolgerung ich glaube das wird
problem was sie auch vorhin angesprochen
dass auch in ihrem vorbericht gezeigt
haben dass immer mehr menschen in
deutschland wenig vertrauen haben oder
weniger vertrauen haben zu diesem zeit
hat ja nichts in erster linie mit den
zahlen zu tun sondern insgesamt mit
corona politik der letzten zwei jahren
die unsicherheit was gilt heute was gilt
morgen und beispielsweise ist auch das
ist auch normal ist werden auch
äußerungen geben es wird immer
feststellung der politik geben die dann
kurz danach wieder von der realität
geholt
insgesamt verknüpfen ja die regierung
verknüpft ja die ministerpräsidenten und
die bundesregierung verknüpft ja die
zahlen mit der politik oder umgekehrt
das heißt wir sehen das ja ganz genau
zum beispiel bei der hospitalisierung
die inzidenz da wird ein wert angegeben
und wenn der wert erreicht ist dann
folgende maßnahmen genauso vorher bei
den infektionen oder bei den instituts
werden das heißt die zahlen sind ja
politisch total wichtig und jetzt lernen
wir eben immer mehr die zahlen stimmen
nicht das ist ja ein riesenproblem kann
in dem licht überhaupt der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung am 17 januar stattfinden
wenn der falsche zahlen oder zumindest
nicht realistische zahlen auf den tisch
kommt das bund länder treffen was sie
ansprechen sollte auf jeden fall
stattfinden das dort man trifft sich
auch nicht um in erster linie über die
zahlen zu reden sondern letztendlich
welche schlussfolgerung man ziehen wird
aus den daten die man in der
vergangenheit in der vergangenheit
bekommen hat sie nicht richtig ich würde
nicht sagen dass diese zahlen nicht
richtig sind diese zahlen sind manchmal
nicht genau aber letztendlich sind sie
eine orientierung während natürlich eine
regionale der
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach der sagt die zahlen die das
lka auf den tisch legt zur omikron die
liegen in der realität zwei bis dreimal
höher wenn sie im tank noch zehn liter
haben und es zeigt aber nur einen liter
an dann haben sie gewaltiges problem auf
der autobahn absolut mein
gesundheitsminister den sie angesprochen
haben auch eine interessante
beschreibungen gesundheitsminister unser
aller gesundheitsminister
orientiert selbst hält sich
selbstverständlich an diesen zahlen aber
letztendlich ist auch entscheiden wie
wir gemeinsam aus dieser pandemischen
situation herauskommen das ist doch die
entscheidende frage und dort gibt es die
absprachen auch dementsprechend mit den
ländern und wir werden hier über eine
reihe von maßnahmen reden die uns oder
instrumente reden die uns in den
nächsten wochen verhältnismäßig durch
diese pandemische krise führen können
das ist das entscheidende und die
statistik das ist definitiv nicht meine
aufgabe an der stelle die richtigkeit zu
bewerten ja oder nein sondern damit wird
jetzt gearbeitet habe und daraus werden
dann schlussfolgerungen lassen sie uns
mal über die schluss forderungen die man
ableitet aus mehr oder weniger
stimmenzahl mal sprechen sind ja mehrere
dinge die im raum stehen die impfpflicht
die fdp erster fördern dagegen sprechen
wir über omikron man fragt sie soll man
die quarantänezeit
verkürzen was genau sind ihre vorschläge
schauen sie mal wenn sie mich im sommer
gefragt hätten wenn sie mir im sommer
die frage gestellt hätten mit mir bin
ich für die allgemeine impfpflicht oder
gegen die allgemeine insel ich kann mir
gefragt mitgenommen hätte ich hätte ich
ganz klar gesagt im sommer hätte ich
gesagt ich bin gegen die allgemeine
impfpflicht so jetzt haben wir eine
andere situation
die pandemische entwicklung oder die der
entwicklung ist anders gekommen als ich
das im sommer noch gedacht hatte und
jetzt haben wir diese debatte im
deutschen bundestag wird eine
fraktionsübergreifende entscheidung dazu
zustande kommen es wird gruppenanträge
kommen wir werden sehen was das für
gruppenanträge senden eigentlich es gibt
noch keinen einzigen der jetzt vorliegt
es gibt es gibt gruppen anträge die
gerade bearbeitet werden
zwei davon kenne ich auch schon selbst
aber wie gesagt die werden gerade alle
noch vorbereitet sind natürlich die
unterschiedlichen varianten der debatte
die abgedeckt werden für die allgemeine
impfpflicht gegen die allgemeine
impfpflicht aber nicht desto trotz die
die dinge verändern sich schnell und sie
merken dass ja auch allein bei dieser
debatte das was ich beispielsweise im
sommer gesagt habe ist heute schon von
der realität überholt worden das ist
diese entwicklung die für uns alle ja
letztendlich neu ist und deswegen
entsteht auch bei den menschen draußen
die unsicherheit nach dem motto wie so
ändern die permanente ihre meinung das
ist aber leider in dieser situation so
weil wir auch eine vergleichbare
situation noch nicht hatten im sommer
wenn sie mich gefragt hätten wenn wir
dieses gespräch im sommer geführt hätten
ich wusste im sommer nicht dass wir es
irgendwann mal mit einer harmonika die
war schon immer für die impfpflicht und
es gibt politiker die waren schon immer
dagegen die haben ihren der zeit
geändert sie haben ihre meinung geändert
und das hat natürlich eine
glaubwürdigkeit auch zum
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust auch beigetragen
auch die fdp wie sie ihre haltung in der
zeit verändern die debatte die debatte
über die allgemeine impfpflicht die gibt
es in allen parteien
das ist es nicht ein phänomen was nur in
der fdp schauen sie mal fand sie schauen
sie mal die debatte beispielsweise im
ethikrat an wie differenziert diese
debatte war da gab's personen da gab es
experten die am ende gesagt haben wir
sind gegen die allgemeine impfpflicht
und selbst die die sich für die
allgemeine impfpflicht ausgesprochen
haben haben gesagt wir haben aber
unterschiedliche vorstellungen von der
umsetzung wir haben unterschiedliche
vorstellungen
was was die altersstufen anbetrifft die
einen waren für ab 18 die anderen
wollten ab 60 dass die debatte ist
extrem komplex und es ist definitiv
keine parteipolitische debatte sondern
das ist eine medizinisch ethischen
debatte und die sollten auszuführen das
bedeutet es wird so weitergehen und der
vertrauensverlust kann überhaupt gar
nicht aufgefangen werden weil man am
ende eigentlich immer nur hört na gut
wir wussten zu dem zeitpunkt noch nicht
was wir jetzt wissen wenn ich jetzt auf
die schau dann kann ich mir vorstellen
werde ich diesen satz noch sehr viel
öfter hören was auch dazu führen könnte
dass noch mehr menschen das vertrauen
verlieren ich kann das nachvollziehen
vor allem kann ich die enttäuschung die
damit verbunden ist nachvollziehen wie
gesagt ich selbst wenn hätte beispiel
sehr im jahr 2020 silvester 2020 war ich
der meinung 20 21 werden wir die
pandemie ganz klar hinter uns lassen und
diese enttäuschung ist ja ist ja bei mir
oder auch bei politikern ist auch enorm
groß ich meine wir sehen ja bürgern
dieses landes wir leben in diesem land
und dementsprechend ist die enttäuschung
groß dass wir uns immer noch nach so
langer zeit mit diesen themen
beschäftigen und vor allem was mich im
nachhinein ärgert und wie gesagt ich
gehöre nicht zu den menschen die auch
die lottozahlen im vorfeld schon kennen
also diese leute gibt es auch die immer
im nachhinein alles besser wissen aber
die enttäuschung ist auch groß dass aus
meiner sicht das land unvorbereitet in
diese vierte welle reingegangen ist das
hätte uns oder beziehungs hätte der
gesamten politik nicht passieren dürfen
ich will nicht an dieser stelle die alte
bundesregierung noch mal kritisieren
aber das land ist unvorbereitet in
dieser vierte welle reingegangen und
muss es das leider und zu den quarantäne
regeln das ist so wichtigen moment für
den alltag der deutschen sei es an
schulen oder bei der arbeit wofür
plädieren sie andere länder haben sie
uns schon vorgemacht großbritannien
südafrika beispielsweise die viel mehr
erfahrung schon mit omikron haben die
haben gesagt es muss nur noch der in
quarantäne derzeit tatsächlich omikron
hat alle anderen nicht mehr kommt dass
in deutschland sind sie dafür und wenn
ja wann das wird man sehen das wird ja
eine wesentliche komponente der
diskussion am freitag sein wofür sich
persönlich aus meiner sicht ist es
nachvollziehbar in der jetzigen
situation vor allem vor dem hintergrund
was jetzt auf uns kommen könnte
ernsthaft darüber nachzudenken die
quarantäne verordnung zu ändern vor
allem für gebuchte zu ändern ich halte
das für plausibel ich halte das war so
das wegfällt die quarantäne oder dass
man nur so mutig ist dass man sich ein
bisschen verkürzt dass man so mutig ist
und kraftvoll ein wenig verkürzt aber
nicht desto trotz das müssen die leute
entscheiden die tatsächlich auch tief in
dieser materie sind und sich damit
beschäftigen ich werde das jetzt nicht
detailliert hier kommentieren weil ich
dann vermutlich in 34 tagen wieder dann
oder in einer woche wenn sie mich wieder
einladen hier stehe um möglicherweise
sage das war falsch oder ist wieder von
der realität überholt worden
menschen sind den sich tief mit der
materie beschäftigt absolut absolut oder
das sind politiker gar nicht mehr
festlegen das kann ja auch keine lösung
sein dass man nur noch das abwartet und
9 dass das stimmt so nicht wir haben
gerade als fdp weil sie auch vorhin die
fdp angesprungen wir haben ja bewusst
wert darauf gelegt dass die entscheidung
wie man mit der pandemie geht das diese
entscheidung wieder im deutschen
bundesland getroffen worden vorher in
den monaten davor war ja der bundestag
immer außen vor wir haben quasi diese
entscheidung in dem parlament wieder
zurückgeholt wir zeigen ihnen zum
abschluss noch ein foto vom
us-präsidenten der hatte mal ein tag
pause ist dann spazieren gegangen am
strand mit seiner frau und seinem hund
der commander heißt sinnvollerweise und
hier sehen den us präsidenten joe biden
vielleicht kommen wir gleich kurz zeigen
der am strand völlig alleine mit seiner
ehefrau und seinem schäferhund eine
maske trägt wie finden sie das sollte er
das tun
finden sie dass vernünftig finden sie
dass alba also das ist seine persönliche
entscheidung der kann von mir aus auch
ein motorrad helm tragen also das ist
seine persönliche entscheidung wie er am
strand unterwegs ist mit seinem hund
oder demnächst mit der katze aber das
ist ihm überlassen
und also es ist ein bisschen befremdlich
oder ein bisschen befremdlich
waren hunderte security leute dabei alle
aus dem fotografen ich denke er wusste
dass er fotografiert wird das sind ja
alles auch pr profis von daher sollten
wir nicht überbewerten
dank an den künftigen fdp
generalsekretär bei uns bei bild live im
studio heute 3
dank